you've been making 210 spending 310 I'm
getting ready to put you on 30.
you're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless it's your extra job or
you're waiting on some of the people you
work with during the day
okay this is how humbling this is going
to be
quiet it's going to crush a lot of crap
in your soul that caused you to do this
so the bad news is it's going to be
really rough the good news is it's going
to be great for you guys relationally
spiritually and financially
but you're not going to make the
financial unless you make the relational
on the spiritual move because I know
that I know you guys because I was you
guys this is exactly what I did it's
exactly what I did in my 20s I bought
and purchased a lifestyle that was 5 to
10 x what I had yeah and it was all
because of crap inside of me that caused
me to do that